chris hemsworth thinks Charlize Theron
should be the next James Bond but what
does she think you're great
on Monday char Lisa's snow-white and
Huntsman co-star revealed to W Magazine
that he thinks she should be the first
female bond she embodies kind of every
sort of ounce of strength and the
ability and dignity and integrity that
that character should have and she's
smart as hell she's physically able et
caught up with a 41 year old actress on
Monday at the Berlin premiere for her
new flick atomic blonde God I think I
love you
that's Chiba and asked her to weigh in
Krista you got that check I sent you
thanks dude I got your back so would she
be down to replace Daniel Craig and suit
up as double-oh-seven all of the talk
around it and I find very flattering but
it's a little overwhelming you know it's
all of it is really great but
overwhelming the names bond James Bond
you got the job because I'm not gonna
take that job away from you you
cray-cray
[Music]
you